mind your decisions i'm presh talwalkar
the first term of an infinite series is
one divided by five root four plus four
root five
the second term is one divided by six
root five plus five root six
the pattern continues indefinitely
what is the value of this infinite
series
i was suggested this problem by a
student in indonesia
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
a general term in this series is 1
divided by n multiplied by the square
root of n minus 1
plus n minus 1 multiplied by the square
root of n
we can simplify this fraction with the
classic trick of multiplying the
numerator and denominator by the
conjugate
the result will be a difference of
squares
we'll take the square of the first term
minus the square of the second term
this is the resulting fraction
we can then factor the denominator by
factoring the quantity n multiplied by n
minus 1.
we then simplify the denominator
we now have a single term in the
denominator so we can divide through
we end up with the following result
it'll be equal to the square root of n
minus 1
over n minus 1 minus the square root of
n over n
we will use this formula to simplify
each term in the series we'll apply this
formula to the first term
here n is equal to five
we thus get the result of the square
root of four over four
minus the square root of five over 5.
we apply the formula to the second term
here n is equal to 6.
then we apply this formula to the third
term and here n is equal to 7.
this pattern continues indefinitely
we'll simplify the result
notice we have a negative square root of
5 over 5 plus a square root of 5 over 5
and these two terms will cancel
the following two terms will also cancel
and this pattern will continue
indefinitely
the only term that survives is the very
first term
this is reminiscent of a telescope that
retracts upon itself
for this reason this type of sum is
known as a telescoping sum
all of the terms vanish except the very
first term
this simplifies to be 2 over four which
is equal to one half and that's our
answer
it's a pretty radical and neat sum
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you